breaking tonight tens of thousands of
migrants are making their way toward the
u.s southern border as we speak the
panamanian government says most of those
travelers are haitian also tonight new
images of americans tax dollars wasted
after the biden administration takes new
steps to specifically abandon a physical
border wall championed by the previous
administration with fox team coverage
tonight bill millusion is in southern
texas where authorities who are already
overwhelmed by the surge are bracing for
a new onslaught but we begin with griff
jenkins in panama a crucial gateway for
the incoming migrants good evening griff
good evening brad we are the first tv
journalist to come here to the lahos
blancas migrant camp in southern panama
it opened in may of 2020 and it is the
same waypoint that most of those 15 000
haitians passed through on their way to
that bridge in del rio three weeks ago
so he came here to see where the border
crisis begins long before it reaches the
u.s
a pipeline of haitian migrants streaming
towards the u.s begins thousands of
miles south of the american southern
border panama's foreign minister erica
muynes says there are currently 60 000
migrants passing through her country
with another 20 thousand waiting to
cross from columbia but that crossing is
through some of the most treacherous
terrain on earth the darien gap a
lawless jungle inaccessible by road
ruled by drug traffickers smugglers and
bandits who prey on the migrants it is
the only break in the pan-american
highway from alaska to the tip of south
america and many never make it through
they mention a lot of places
migrants
now graves are dug in nearby towns like
agua freya for those who perish along
the way
yet the international organizational
migration says that more than 91 000
migrants have successfully made it
through the gap this year as the
pipeline has turned profitable on the
columbian side residents are being
thrown out of their homes to make room
for a place to stay for paying haitians
around 100 homes have been taken from
local renters to give them to haitians
and around 50 commercial locales have
also been taken or contracts have been
ended to rent to haitians
the next stop in their journey shelters
here in southern panama that our cameras
got an exclusive look at you saw dead
bodies yes
so many dead bodies really yes it was it
was
it was
i was really shocked when i saw them and
and i was like wow just forget about it
we just have to focus
and do what we had to do
bread the conditions here in this camp
are a humanitarian crisis though the
panamanian officials are doing the best
they can to deal with it they say that
some 500 to a thousand migrants arrive
every single day coming through that
darian gap but some 500 also leave on
buses that you see behind me that bus
just like many before it all day goes
straight to the costa rican border where
they'll be let out to continue their
journey the cost for a ride forty
dollars brett taking off now watch after
that bus griff jenkins live in panama
griff thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else